- Like speaking of your kids,
are they little big shots?
Do they do stuff that really shock you?
- They shock me a lot.
- Yeah.
- I mean they're
perfectly weird and funny.
In the best way.
- So they're you?
- Ben my husband is like
much quieter and mellower,
but he's super weird.
I'm not gonna let him off the hook.
And our kids are this
weird amalgamation of us.
And then you really start to
see their ownselves come in.
So I see me, I see Ben.
I always think I'm like if
I just don't screw you up
you'll be amazing.
Like if I had it my way
I would stuff them both
in Babybjorn.
- Like a kangaroo.
- For sure.
And I'm always like just sit up here.
My oldest is 12 but she's my height now
and I'm literally always like come here.
Come here.
- Get on over here.
- Come here.
I know I'm like get right
here on momma's lap.
She's like that's just odd.
We're in the same--
Like I'm wearing your shoes I
don't wanna sit on your lap.
- Rude.
(laughing)